oh you see that sign that says there
then Mitchell the wall is undefeated you
are at the wall now do you know what the
wall do you know do you know what the
wall is no please tell me Bill can you
explain to the wall please
yeah the wall is basically the part
where I would say roughly around age
when a woman reaches age 30
. so looks 28 is about to start yeah
yeah it's about the start of it but yeah
but I think 30 is a typical Benchmark
and that's when her looks start to go
downhill her ability to attract men or
the same standard of men that she did
when she was in her prime which is
usually sort of late teens to mid-20s
starts to shrink and at that point her
dating pool obviously starts to shrink
as well
um and really the goal for a lot of
women is to bag the guy
the she wants when she's in her prime
so I would say that at the age of 28
you're pretty much at that upper limit
towards the end of your best period to
be able to get the guy that you want
because what happens with a lot of women
right is during their Prime they'll have
a certain standard of guy and that's
what they're used to once they hit the
wall they still because you know it's
very hard for them to go down once
they've had a guy that meets a certain
type of criteria right so they end up in
this Perpetual cycle once they've hit
the wall where they still have these
high standards but they can't get that
guy anymore so yeah the aim of the game
is really to try and bag that guy and
commitment long-term commitment from
that guy before they hit the wall so I
think what what what this guy is
basically saying is that
you haven't really got much time and do
you really want to be using the
the latter stages of your Prime on
basically a long shot yeah I'll be
willing that so
um I'm just have some stuff that I've
written about the wall our primary
agency is our sexuality and how good we
look smv is a desirability to the
opposite sex 18 we
between the the wall is between the ages
of 18 and 28 or our primary agencies
between the ages of 18 and 28 when we
live to be 90. men between the ages of
20 and 70 rate 22 23 and 24 year olds as
the most attractive it's not an age but
a mindset it is the subconscious
acknowledgment that she cannot compete
in the same way she did when she was
younger
yeah so the reason I want them to
explain it to you because I want you to
understand that if you are 28 and you're
without you you don't have any children
and I'm trying to make you understand
right now that makes you high over here
you know we are respecting that you
don't have any children so remember what
we said we treat you as a virgin so if a
woman hasn't got any children we don't
know body count she's good to go
um for you to be to waste the next year
or two years and push you potentially to
29.30 for a guy that lives in the USA
when you already know geriatric
pregnancy starts and this whole thing
about about
um
about freezing the eggs and IVF I know
people have done IVF have spent over 50
Grand in IVF and they still didn't work
um I have family members that spent a
lot of money and it didn't work in the
end God had to you know I mean you could
have to boss them if you you're not a
Kardashian so you won't be able to just
freeze your eggs we don't so a lot of
the options that women think they have
they're not reserved for them they're
reserved for for people that have a lot
of money that can do these things on the
top on top of that these things don't
guarantee any results so I think
for you to be speaking to someone
potentially that would and stop you from
interacting with anyone else and then in
America I just I just I just unless a
man is telling you and he's literally
putting money into your account and
saying I'm setting up a life for you to
come I I suggest you start looking for
different options okay I've been real
with you yeah because because because if
I was your brother there's no way I'm
gonna be like so what you're holding up
for this guy over there no my sister
this is what we need to do and I don't
want to see you get to 30. and then
you're out in we are first of all
looking for man yeah to get me
don't make sense no
no because I think you're a good case I
think you're a good case study I think
you're a woman no no I think I think a
woman that you said you know for 10
years you've been out the game
necessarily
um you know when we're spoken to you
what you want you want to you want a
complete family unit probably based on
some of the things that you've
experienced you're 28 you don't have any
child like and you know you honest you
had you had therapy so you understand
some of the things you've gone through
you're you're a candidate now for for a
good man but you need to listen to some
of the things that I've said so when
this good man comes you don't scare him
away with saying stuff like I won't
listen to you you know what I mean I
never said no but but what I'm trying to
say to you is this if you explained it
the way that you did afterwards about
like how men would feel when it comes to
women going out to the club like you
made it seem a little bit more different
but I didn't I didn't I personally
wasn't looking at it the way that you
explained it like you you she he said it
in more in a secure way like it made it
seem a little bit more like okay I can
understand your point of view before it
was just like blunt like if I said you
can't go you can't go like oh well I
don't know you're talking to you
I didn't say that I didn't say no but it
came across that way to me yes well well
if you know for the for the modern women
out there that want to learn to be wives
and we're opening a wife School
we're gonna bring in wives from all over
to teach teach modern women how to cook
clean
dancing and why cooking I clean can
I ask you a question though yeah so you
got this guy in America right let's say
you were to be out wherever and you met
a guy that was you know ticked all your
boxes and he was serious about trying to
get to know you
would you say no to him for the goddess
in America I've gone through that and
I've come right back to square one I've
done I've done that so somebody that I
saw as a potential so me as a potential
wanted to move forward
I don't know what happened but it didn't
go the way I wanted it to go to or the
way that he said it was going to go to
so I just left it for what it was and
then I rekindled what I have now going
on right now so was he a bad boy what
the guy that I used to talk yeah the one
over here no he was a good boy
um he was he was actually a good boy
yeah but I told her already with this
situation that she has over there I told
her
wait without waiting yeah like if that's
what you're gonna do then that's what
you're gonna do but don't forget yeah
see I want better results for for men
I'm a man so I want better results for
us but I want better results for women
so this thing when I said to you about
yo what Champion for women like it
sounds mad because men haven't spoken
like this but we have to get the
backlash on the corn for it we have to
get people chopping us up and making
edits and trying to make it change the
narrative we have to get this we have to
get our colleagues that said oh my God I
see oh your views are so misogyny we
have to get all of this but the reason
we get this because it's that vitally
important for us to get this message
across there's so many men that don't
have a voice there's so many men that
are scared to speak and more importantly
women are scared to speak so since I've
come on this my third time I've been on
here I did not think it would cause as
many Ruffles as it has right but I
understand why but what we need I get so
many women in my DMs that call me that
message me that's even in a few in the
comments that support what we're doing
but the problem is there's a minority of
of women that are speaking for the
majority and this minority is loud and
they are rude and they are crude and
they rep and they are now their voices
representing the larger um the law
they've also represented for the
majority right so when we speak and then
it doesn't sound in the beginning we
maybe bump our heads a little bit but we
actually come to a place of where you
understand that actually you know what I
didn't think of it like this my mind's
got a point that's the point we need
women to to Jump by us and be like right
okay cool these guys are actually trying
to help people get better results
because by you understanding now or
automatically I know you're going to get
better results you're going to look at
yourself you're going to look at your
time you're going to think to yourself
it's all how you say it too because like
like I said
the beginning from where we was that's
not what you sounded like to where we
are right now I feel like if you sit
down and talk to me I will listen if I
feel like you'll demanding me and I
don't understand what you're saying to
me I'm gonna be a bit like who are you
talking to you know no it was a
hypothetical situation though wasn't it
because it came down to your friendship
with um with your friend Aaron you were
kind of just like no I wouldn't listen
so I guess we were just giving how a man
would perceive that but you know what I
mean I also think you're asking a man to
communicate like women
and so and so you're asking men are very
blunt and they're very direct and
they're not really trying to think about
your feelings and be considered unless
they're more feminine typically well
then and so and so when you say like you
need to communicate to me this way
you're basically saying be more like a
woman I don't feel like I'm saying that
I feel I don't think you mean to no I
don't feel like I'm saying that I feel
like I'm I don't think it's a problem
for anybody to be very
open and explain thoroughly about what
they're talking about because why is it
that you say JUMP I must I must jump
because men don't have the time to
explain every single decision that they
make and so it's like exhausting to them
so if you if he says hey can you do this
and you say why and then he has to have
a 10 minute conversation with you for
you to agree with it and now and now
you'll do it it's like that's exhausting
to a guy they would rather just have a
guy a girl that just says okay it's
because at that point at that point
yeah it goes back to what we're saying
about a woman who a girlfriend a wife
who won't listen is really a big turn
off to a guy I feel like and it's
another podcast like it's cool I mean it
gives me content it's cool I'm not I'm
not complaining but like in a day-to-day
relationship like that's exhausting to
men they don't they don't men don't like
to sit around and talk to us I feel like
I'll be the voice for women that can
actually say if you speak to me where I
understand then I can listen if you're
demanding me from somebody who doesn't
have a father figure in her life like
that you have to understand how to treat
certain women not every woman is going
to be the same and not every man is
going to be the same what outcomes are
you looking for there
um what outcome yeah you don't
understand it no but in terms of
relationships what are you looking for
like do you want to be married to a
relationship I would love to I would
like to be married I'm not going to
pinpoint and just say like I'm going to
be married tomorrow if it doesn't happen
it doesn't happen but I feel like my
main source or what I'm looking for is
true happiness and peace
irrespective of whether that's a
relationship because the reason I'm in a
relationship so in a relationship like
you were saying and I agree men tend to
be The Gatekeepers and the decision
makers as to whether something goes to a
relationship or a marriage so if you're
not behaving so what you'll do you're
setting a criteria and saying a guy has
to explain this to a certain way but as
far as relationships and marriage is
concerned you're not in a position to
lay out that criteria it's the guide
that's laying out the criteria and
saying listen
I expect my girlfriend if she trusts me
and she wants to be with me to listen to
what I'm saying it doesn't mean she
doesn't have a voice but ultimately if I
have something to say I can't I haven't
got time to be drawing her a diagram and
giving all these long-winded
explanations if she's not willing to
listen to me she hasn't really selected
me as her man and and another thing like
when you say like what are you looking
for like relationships and marriage it's
not about happiness it's about Duty and
so when a guy when a guy hears and I'm
just telling you this is just from a
guy's point of view like when they hear
like what do you want out of a
relationship and they say happiness
that's a red flag because your happiness
can come and go and it's like if you're
not happy tomorrow you're gonna leave
and the number one thing that men look
for is loyalty and so if you're not like
to that that says to a guy like I'll
leave if I'm not happy
and and that with with all the risk that
men have to take today in order to get
married it's it's like you know we're
asking them to do this but we give them
red flags along the way and this is
where there's not a lot of marriage is
going on there's less marriages in
comparison to our parents generation
feminine feminism sorry has given women
an unrealistic expectation of what of
what relationships and marriage really
are you know I I genuinely believe that
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis basis on this platform if
you want to help please consider sending
a super thanks below every donation
helps and it helps make what we do
possible